Well,
at the end of December,
at the end of 2023,
the Minister of Inclusions,
social security and migration,
the massaid,
announced at a press conference that during
the first half of 2024,
that is,
during the 6/1 months of this 2024,
we were going to have a new reform
in the immigration regulations.
This reform was to have two specific objectives that
although we still do not know exactly
what they will consist of in detail,
how they will materialize
if we have what the general lines are.
On the one hand,
this new regulation reform is intended to
improve,
increase,
protect the rights of foreigners in Spain
and on the other hand,
simplify,
make more efficient
all immigration regulations
and reducing unnecessary procedures.
As we will now see.
This is undoubtedly very,
very important news.
Why?
Because as you may already know,
whenever we talk
of reforms to the immigration regulations
make them easier,
new advantages and many benefits for you
foreigner in Spain
or that it will do so soon.
So much because it will be improved
your situation as a foreigner in the country.
How?
New avenues will be created,
will be facilitated
all those options you have
to enter Spain and
get your residence permit,
even bring your relatives,
have a residence
in the country in the long term with your family,
as happened at the end of 2022,
that there was a major regulation reform
that affected the Arraigos
to the student visa,
to the work permit.
These reforms are super important,
to take them into account,
they must be monitored.
and stay tuned,
even before publication,
what we are going to do.
Again,
we still don't know all the details,
what we do know,
as we have told you,
is that there are two main lines of action,
the increase
of these rights of foreigners in Spain,
and the second,
and perhaps one of the points that will be most important,
more relevant in this reform,
will be the simplification one.
as of today there are many residence permits
similar.
There are procedures that are complicated,
a little and that generate redundancies and inefficiencies,
longer waiting times,
greater difficulty for,
in this case,
for you,
to get your residence permit.
What this reform is going to propose is a
simplification
in a reduction of different residence permits,
what I could do
that getting yours was an easier task.
In addition,
there is also about to be something that is often
passes with the reforms,
what is mass regularization
of foreigners.
In the previous reform
was done more or less indirectly,
through the facilitation
of some permits
of rooted residences,
with the creation of a new arraigo
as was the rooting for the training.
We are waiting to see what will happen in this case,
if this massive regularization is to occur
Before,
after During and how it will happen again,
in this video we propose
this new reform that will take place very soon,
6/1 months
of this year of this new year 2 024 remembers,
to be